that was a very similar to what we did
before and we went from a function to
the first the second is I'm going to
extend this idea a little bit okay which
an overhang I have not given you a
function I give you into riveting the
first derivative and we're going to draw
some conclusions about what the function
and what the second derivative are okay
so this is a little bit tricky but we're
going to think first about going from
here to the secondary frozen first to
the second derivative okay so firstly I
notice that this guy here has a turning
point right right there so what am I
going to do with that where's that gonna
go think back to the mother of all it's
getting your number what it's going to
go down to here because that beaded
zebra but if the Secretariat is zero and
everything's continuous down hola I have
every reason to expect that in the
actual function i should have a point of
inflection so i'm going to draw my
straight line up and down to indicate
okay there you go so I've got a rough
idea of where things are going to go
that is going to tell me down here it's
like that now so that I do not confuse
it with the actual function I'm just
going back to my first page I reserve
these reds and greens I reserve them for
the actual function okay because you can
get start to get confused when you talk
about the grading of the gradient which
gradient is the gradient that you are we
wrapping your radio again so don't
confuse yourself I'm going to keep all
my colors up here but in order to graph
this second derivative positively I do
actually want to think about the grading
of the gradient function okay so this
guy here is increasing what you see my
color I'm just using this so I don't
confuse it with the top graph it hits 0
and then it's decreasing so what does
that tell me about the region's down
here for the second derivative the
region's down here do they not
correspond to the signs up here yeah so
I'm going to go and positive here and
negative here you're happy with that
again this is a straight line because
I'm expecting this is more or less than
quadratic okay so i'm going to draw my
straight line
okie dokie now that I've gone down I'm
going to lose both of these to draw up
words okay I've already identified where
I'm expecting our point of inflection to
be okay when you look at the first
derivative the most important points on
the first derivative I'll where they are
0 you see that so I'm going to draw
upwards from these two this is where D 1
PX 0 0 y 0 DX is equal 0 there clear is
also equal to 0 here so this should tell
me what about the actual function Mila
slavery yeah this they're stationary
points right then maybe max then maybe
midnight of your horizontal points of
inflection I'll find out intersector
right so I'm going to draw office
okay now this is great because we want
you to do is take all that form thinking
we've done before and I'll use our logic
to draw this graph okay now you can see
I have got a stationary point here right
usually a traditional question would
algebraically say determine the nature
of the stationary point but you've
already determined it's their job what
have you used you've done the second
derivative right look you've got a
stationary point the second derivative
is positive which means it's concave up
ok so this corresponds to a minimum up
here ok so therefore this is going to be
a bit informal I'm going to draw a low
stationary point here it's low because
it's going to be a minimum right and
just indicate I'm gonna have sort of
upturned edges to that station or a
point you see that I don't know enough
yet to join the dots properly so i don't
wanna draw too much of em and mess
myself I and because i'm drawing your
pen which is good morning so I've got my
minimum then I come over here there's
another stationary point right and I
have already determined its nature the
second derivative is negative meaning is
concave down right so therefore this guy
here is a max yes so I'm going to draw
that stationary point higher because
it's a relative maximum and then I've
got these downturn bits here you ok with
that ok excellent I'm almost ready to go
in between here from this stationary
point to this stationary point I have to
go up what do I have that corresponds to
that in my derivatives increases yeah
good so I've got this this first
derivative here is positive if you see
that so of course this product has to be
increasing all right let's try and draw
it and as carefully as we can we know
where to expect the point of reflection
let's
the shot
ok so it's rough I can't fix it now
because it's in but you can get the idea
you can obviously fix it up you can do
it lightly in pencil and then fix it up
properly once you've got the whole
picture there ok so there's
approximately my point of inflection and
again you can informally say yeah that
looks that's pretty concave down to me I
can back that up and that also looks
pretty concave up even if it's a bit
weekly okay all right now on the outside
let's think about this over here on the
right of our maximum what does the first
derivative tell me it's the first
derivative is negative really that this
is decreasing like that like a good
healthy i- a cubic sure right and then
on the left er it's also decreasing
right left to right so it's coming down
like so until against the stationary
point which is also a turning point and
there it is I'm done you can of course
verify it by doing this pattern from
before look I've got decreasing
decreasing decreasing decreasing which
maps to this I've got increasing
increasing increasing increasing all the
way up to the stationary point which
corresponds to here and then decreasing
and I can do the same thing with the
concavity with the concavity concave up
then I hit my stationary point right and
then it looks pretty concave down to me
question have you newest ships it up or
down okay that's a fantastic question
okay and I'm sorry going to a stick as
always I'd have to rhetorically asked
myself remember and I've got schiphol
airport workers up remember I are I'm
very very informally talks about this
and now is the right time to talk about
it if you differentiate a function like
this you know exactly what its
derivative will be okay you know that
what you differentiate okay you're going
to get no ambiguity 2x do i M DX is 2x
okay now this is kind of what we were
doing before in terms of you start with
a function that you go to its derivative
then you go to it some then you go to
its second derivative and again there's
no doubt you know exactly what it has to
be okay but I'm not placed you in a
different position I placed you in this
position and I've said now can you go
back up you go back up and the problem
is it's not a problem it's just reality
I could go back up to this guy but I
could go up to a whole series of other
different functions as well I could go
to this guy right or that I could just
as equally it got to this guy okay okay
I could go up to I can go up to this guy
I could go to anything I like so long as
come on managers favorite moment so long
as like what binds all of these together
is the x squared what separates them all
out well what does separate more how
would you work that's the constant term
hey on the end right the y-intercept
exactly right which just corresponds to
vertical shift okay so what we do is you
say look at these guys right and this is
the language i'm going to just tell your
back mclean door it's not going to be
into this particular test but it's the
right time to let it these are
derivatives going down do differentiate
differentiate
you get derivatives if you go in the
opposite direction like these things
that I came from we call these guys and
maybe is worth writing it down we call
these primitives this is where I came
from yes i have i have briefly mentions
because people like a zombie assessment
notifications people said eh what's that
about that's what these are around okay
now being that you told me and they've
all got the x squared in common or they
differ by is a constant okay all of
these primitives this family acrimony
are all of your same form their overall
bottom x squared and then there's the
addition of a constant ok now the
concert is well it's to indicate that c
is a constant any other variable we say
see hey in some it's a real number it's
not just like ooh what's this Pro
numeral that's it's an actual number it
could be 10 minus 300 1 minus PI but
it's a number okay and what's you
differentiate you be there yeah um from
this derivative yes that's right so if i
gave you a different derivative if the
derivative i gave you and I've got I've
got other ones coming if the derivative
I gave you would say well what one like
this well my distributive big weights
right this this derivative is clearly a
minus x squared right I guess you know I
don't know it could be something like
minus oops right minus X minus 1 X minus
2 that looks like the roots could be
that right so that gives me the Ritz and
that turns it upside down now this guy
is going to have completely different
primitives to this guy right as you can
see that top guy certainly doesn't look
like x squared plus set of me okay but
the important thing is the question was
how do I know up or down where it is an
answer is it can be up or down anywhere
you like they're all valid primitives
okay so i could have draw this higher I
guess what this is saying is I don't
know anything about these intercepts
they mean nothing to me okay